I'm Kathryn manga award for reason TV
and i'm here with reason foundation
polling director Emily Ekins who's going
to break down our second reason roop
pull thanks for joining me Emily thanks
for having me so let's start with the
headline which is we're ten years after
911 and Americans have some opinions
about that well we found that eighty
percent of americans believe that the
security measures implemented after the
911 attacks have made us safer overall
but at the same time that has come with
some costs so for example fifty five
percent of americans say that we've
given up too much freedom and privacy in
the name of security so one of the big
questions post 9-11 is whether there'll
be another attack and the bureaucratic
entity tasked with preventing that is
the Department of the Homeland Security
do americans think that we are
well-positioned ten years out well
interestingly we only found that fifteen
percent of americans are very confident
that the department of homeland security
will prevent another terrorist attack
from occurring on US soil but then forty
percent said that they were somewhat
somewhat confident but still they are
definitely unclear as to whether the
department of homeland security will be
able to achieve its main goal the other
frontline player and security is the
Transportation Security Administration
which is an entity that everyone loves
to hate let's talk about what people
told you about their attitudes about the
TSA the public's evenly divided about
when it comes to whether the TSA will be
able to stop a terrorist trying to board
a US or a plane at a u.s. airport but
interestingly if you look at Democrats
versus Republicans a majority of
Democrats trust that the TSA would
prevent a terrorist from boarding a
plane but conversely a majority of
Republicans don't agree the policy
solution favored by many libertarians in
response to some outcry against
incursions on personal space and privacy
by the TSA has
to privatize it what did you find when
you ask people about that solution well
neither those who favored or oppose that
kind of reform reached in majority 47%
opposed forty-one percent favored but we
did find that a majority of Democrats
opposed privatizing the TSA whereas a
majority of Republicans favored such a
reform ten years out were also still at
war the u.s. is a major presence in
Afghanistan and Iraq and at least
initially the justification for going
into Afghanistan was that it would make
Americans safer what do Americans think
about that attitude now Americans do not
seem to be convinced that being in
Afghanistan and staying in Afghanistan
will make us safer only nineteen percent
said that they believed the u.s. staying
in afghanistan until 2014 at least would
make a safer but sixty-five percent
thought it would really have no impact
and what about in iraq are people
positive on that venture no Americans
are not happy about the war in Iraq was
sixty-two percent thing that it was not
worth it for the u.s. to go in what is
your final finding in this poll in which
you asked about whether the US
government should mind its own business
well essentially that is kind of the
general sentiment that we learn from
this poll is that Americans generally
are favoring a policy where the u.s.
mines its own business we asked when it
came to international military
interventions whether or not the US uses
it too much the right amount not enough
and overwhelmingly 61 percent said the
u.s. uses military force in foreign
conflicts too often thank you very much
Emily for reason TV I'm Catherine manga
award
you